c'est je suis dur avec toi
c'est parce que le monde est dur
tu verras ça
tout ce que je te demande c'est d'éviter
les ennuis tu m'entends
oh merde
ton frère vient de sortir de prison
je sais que j'ai été longtemps absent
mais je veux tu sache une chose tu
compte beaucoup pour moi
fais attention quand et avec lui
bienvenue à la maison
je sais que je dois de l'argent et je
vous la vraie pas à l'envers
laisse nous tranquilles c'est quoi cet
engin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc je les
trouvais il ya forcément quelqu'un qui
cherchait
[Musique]
cette chose que ton frère à là dedans
tu dois en parler à quelqu'un je peux
pas
troublée ils sont pas loin
il ya des mecs dangereux qui veulent
notre peau
[Applaudissements]
je sais que par mégarde
et c'était génial ces moments passés
ensemble comme des frères pour la
première fois
je ne sais pas dans quoi tu l'embarqué
mais il finira par comprendre tu es prêt
pour ça ils sont là
faux
à croire que débile d'aidé
tu m'as tu allais par l'état
eloignez-vous de mon frère
tu devrais peut-être que l'essai sur le
mode